good I'm officer Hawkins sir I'm looking
for Pam is Pam in today yeah that's my
wife is your wife she's
here hi hello Pam how are you doing good
I'm officer Hawkins American Fork Police
Department hi so we had a uh agency
assist out of St George in Springville
that we're just looking for
is okay when you picked her up what was
the uh what was the case did somebody
ask you to pick her up or did you just
pick her up what was going on on well
I'm having guests coming and she came
and did some cleaning for me some
cleaning for
you um you right now in the house in the
living room right here okay great we're
going to have both of you come out here
then if you can just for a second we
just going have to go over some stuff um
you have a warrant yeah we do let me see
it please so it's in my car but right
now my concern is we you just tell them
you're all right well we have to
physically see her that doorway we'll go
ahead and get the copy of the warrant
for you okay you have a warant for my
house specifically for you yeah for you
and the child yeah okay so what is going
as of right now I'll just need you to
give your phone to your husband okay
okay and as of this moment you're going
to be detained right now okay okay okay
so is there is there anything on you uh
no okay perfect just put your hands in
front of you okay just going to place
you temporarily
under I'll explain to you I'll explain
to what are you guys doing I've
explained this already I'm being as
courteous as I can okay okay well I'm
going to call an attorney that's fine I
don't know what's yeah I don't even know
what this is all about okay so I'm going
to explain to you when we get to the car
yes I just explained to you that you're
being detained right
now okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to walk you to my car okay I need
this officer to stay your husband and
I'm going explain everything to you when
we get there
okay so are you familiar with any
officers in Springville no okay are you
do you have siblings or kids in St
George well I have a married daughter
okay what's her name Stacy okay do you
know of any issues that they just went
through today no do you yes I do so
that's why I'm trying to figure out so
we were we were requested by St George
and Springville police to make contact
to here the residents is here than to
detain you currently until questions are
answered okay what kind of questions so
I'm going to call the main officers from
Springville and that's where we're going
to I'm going to tell him that I have you
detained and you can question he can
question you from now does that make
sense so now you know pretty much as
much as I do okay so I'm going to call
him and we're just going to go from
there
okay I'm going off what you're saying
I'm going off what they're saying I
don't know what's the truth I know that
she's here I don't know if she came
willingly or not can't you ask her
that's what we're about to do but as of
right now that's why I separated you cuz
I want the truth I don't want coercion I
don't want her being felt like she has
to say stuff all that kind of stuff okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
put you in there we're going to drive
back to the front so you can hang out
right in front of your house okay Public
Safety how's it going this officer hins
for Police Department how you doing hi
good how are you doing good so I just
want to get some 5 W's on this case I
had so I made contact I have Pam in the
back seat of my car detained in the
house he in the house yep okay we've got
a unit that's going to be heading over
let me find out who it
is her parents were in the situation of
a child abuse allegation okay DCFS made
the report and went to the house and
found children malnourished and locked
in a safe okay in safe in the safe okay
so now those officers and DCFS have to
cussy those children and we're looking
for this
one the rec center when they went to go
find her said that you picked her up
yeah so now they are trying to figure
out why I why you picked her up what you
know with her is she okay is is she did
she come here willingly all that kind of
stuff okay as soon as they come here
yeah we'll be on our way okay okay
that's why I said you're just detained
you're not placed under arrest just
right now until they figure out what's
going on with their par okay okay so as
long as she's not tied up and bound
because you I didn't make her scrub I
didn't make her scrub the floor and they
vacuumed and stuff cuz I have company
coming tonight out of from Costa Rica
okay so but she did of her own free will
we had lunch yeah we went to ry's farm
and had ice
cream those children
are I don't know the full details of how
mistreated or how Mal nourished those
children are okay all I know is that's
the words and treatment that they used
yeah which means that they are severely
concerned of her wellbeing okay and
every child that's in that home okay so
they'll just have to talk to her and and
cuz there has been I've been a part of
many DCFS cases where as soon as the
parents are hooked up kids are taken if
there's any kids that aren't in the home
immediately when the kids are taken
guess what they're scurrying around
other family members are picking them up
that way the parent can come back and
grab them before d FS takes them oh yeah
I'm telling you you may be a good person
but there's a lot of people in this
world that aren't right well if DCFS is
supposed to take her then they can take
her I mean I I'm not going to try to
fight that I mean I you know well that's
what they're going to come talk to you
about they left already so they should
be here in the next 10 15 minutes but
Springville just left as I got off the
phone with him so he's probably going to
be DCFS or whatever it is is coming yeah
so DCFS will come for their part for and
then the
detective she came willingly to my house
and everything is okay and she has to be
taken in state custody oh she does okay
cuz I think her parents are arrested
okay so
um I'm just wondering
uh why they don't
want I know maybe they already no I have
her she's in my house she's in here yeah
I didn't get
told when they he asking that what okay
all right I'm going to go brief your
husband so he's not woring watching okay
so her parents today were on Bas
position for a child abuse child her
DCFS went to the home with Springfield
Police Department and found children in
the basement out nourished and locked in
safe today today yeah what children out
DCFS tried finding all the kids that
were involved and one of them
was we don't know where she's at okay
calls the rec center re Center says that
P picked her up unknown if she went
willingly or forced I'm not saying Pam
forced her I already told her that so we
don't know but what DCFS wants to do is
they have a warrant to pick her up to
take her into State custody because PR
for arresting now her parents were
arrested yes so that's my mom was on her
way to St George mhm that was the whole
thing happened in St George let this go
scre involved and it's traced all its
way back to us somehow I don't know how
you guys are involved you and Pam Pam's
her friend Ruby's friend her husband Uh
Kevin or somebody I've met him a couple
times I don't even
know uh so ham since her mom was on the
way to this
top since since her mom was on the way
to St George then Pam said I'll pick up
the girls and I need some help
and so she said Ruby said they can come
over and help and so they've been
helping clean we have a guest coming
from Costa Rica tonight that's what and
you know they just helped clean they
clean floors they CL all kinds of stuff
I don't I don't even
know so that's the reason we're involved
with this right now just because Pam
went over and Ruby knew that she
get getting into and she got
the so I told Pam as much as I knew from
Spring Field and how much as I knew from
St George that was what I was Ed to come
here locate P inside the residence to
rain and hold on to Pam until spring Z
DCFS
get I don't exactly know what detectives
want with you guys but detectives want
to talk to Pam use FS want to pick
up
I know you guys are probably good people
but there's a lot of people out there
that
aren't okay so she conted around here
and then you went and picked up both of
them were they both in Springville or
were she was at a but what Ace was that
um I don't know maybe they add this it's
some somewhere
like South Spanish Fork yeah I mean no
not Spanish Fork it's past it's past
Spanish for squin we went to the ry's
barn right after I picked her up okay
it's probably Santa Quinn that's
s almost AI type area yeah yeah
okay uh she was at the ace and did you
call both the girls and say hey your mom
told me to come get you no okay how did
you get how did you contact them to know
where they were at I just went to the
the pool and said hey they have a family
emergency can I pick up sht so I just
said family emergency your mom said you
could come help me clean today she said
okay okay and what how did you get
picture up um Ruby just told me she'd be
at the Ace Hardware oh okay so Ruby told
you
we're
okay
okay so they've been here all day we
went to we we went to ry's farm and got
ry's red barn and got ice cream at the
red barn and then we came here and we
scrubbed the floors and vacuumed and
made lunch had BLTs and we were going to
go pick tomatoes and make salsa tonight
okay so that's kind of what we were
doing tonight so just to make sure I'm
understanding all this quickly Ruby
contacted you around noon and said that
they had an around I don't know if
that's short that's your best guess said
she had a family emergeny I need you to
pick up the girls yeah she said would
you mind watching the girls while I'm
gone cuz she was leaving I said yeah I
could do that cuz I need some help
cleaning okay and then did you say to
bring them to your house for today and
then take them back home tonight or to
keep him here for a couple days she
didn't say I was just planning on
bringing him home tonight oh
okay then she
also right there yeah picked them up and
did you pick up first then mhm and then
you went
okay i' been here the besides going to
that Ry red bar we've been here the
whole time okay and you guys have been
cleaning yeah smell my house it smells
great yeah we had lunch we we were we
just finished cleaning and I said okay
what do you guys want to do now I said
we got to go pick the tomatoes once it
gets cool and then we'll learn they
wanted to learn how to make salsa so I
said okay we can do that I said let's
just take a break for a minute and
that's when pounding on the door we
opened the door right up he said ask for
me I came right out and then you
asked come out here and and then like I
said I told him you know what and he
said well I'm not I don't we're not
concerned I said well okay well I she's
in the house and then I don't know what
you did you went to the house and asked
for her her yeah that was cuz
information was slowly getting trickled
with him I don't think he knew about uh
initial CAD notes just said locate
continue until they so that's that's
what happened that's when I've been
we've been at home cleaning this whole
time and dusting and okay just and then
they we were going to pick tomatoes and
make salsa and then take them home okay
so this
is uh pam pam he got a call from Ruby
this morning around here I around I
don't knowly she has Ruby asked her to
pick up the girls um gave them the
locations of where they both would be at
and just said hey we have family
emergency down St GE he want girls and
she said okay so she went down and got
them and they came back here and they've
been
cleaning I just have house guest coming
tonight so I said yeah that'd be great
could they come clean she said yeah
they'd love to do that so yeah so and
then we went to ry's Red Barn got ice
cream on the way cuz they had never been
there before said what you haven't been
ry's Red Barn have you guys been to ry's
Red Barn yeah so we were there and got
ice creams and they bought some things
and then we came straight here where did
you Pi what where did you pick them up
from the um Springville swimming pool oh
you guys went down to S after
no that is hard in
s did she work there or what was she
given there I don't know I just she just
said Ruby gave her oh Ruby just said
she'll be at she'll be at e okay so we
picked up was the ry's Red Barn he said
let's stop here got came home I said
okay you guys can you clean the
downstairs and I'll start vacuuming
upstairs and work for like I don't know
a couple hours and then oh no we had
lunch first we had lunch first and then
we did the cleaning and then we were
just sitting down we just finished
cleaning we just sitting down when we
got the knock on the door and I came
right out and God you know just did
whatever he told me to do
they were Cooperative
yeah you have any questions
for um I really think of well have you
ever have you ever had anything like
this happened before where you picked up
the girls oh like like hey we need you
to watch the girls
last no everything else has been so like
like they wanted to learn how to make
jam and so they had a whole bunch of
strawberries and rasp so I went down
there things like that but you know so I
have interacted with them and we've done
stuff but it's usually to make jam or
learn how to sew or or do something or
like someone has a play or something we
go to see it or something but not you
know they have come to my house before
and done house weeding and stuff like
that okay how did you start to know the
family how me the Frankie family yeah
through a a program called connections
okay it's
a kind of a life skills yeah type thing
oh okay so tell me more about like when
you first met them through the program
or not really know what what the program
is she's just she was just she was a
coach she was a okay what type of things
do they do with the
program um it's like life skills life
skills
like um learning how to you know it's
like be honest responsible and humble
those are those three colors of their of
their
program um is there like a meeting place
for you Med or is it kind of a virtual
place it's online every Saturday morning
it's called empowering Joy
okay how long have you
know oh jeez
is probably
oh GE I don't know let's see I mean I
didn't know her really well cuz she was
in the program but I didn't really know
her but I've known her probably really
well maybe 3
years is this like a program that she
started or is it just one that she kind
of she's just a part of it she just part
of
it okay other questions okay me if we
appreciate you cooperating with us
information and like like they explained
before the whole handcuffs and
everything is just cuz we don't know
really what's going on we don't know who
you are and
[Applause]
so thank
you
in
how many of us are
even
[Music]